breaking news tonight metro police have
identified a man accused in a deadly
stabbing on the strip 58-year-old
freddie allen has been arrested for
stabbing a tourist last night on the
pedestrian bridge near tropicana and las
vegas boulevard and we thank you for
joining us at six o'clock i'm sasha
loftis according to metro police allen
stabbed that victim once before leaving
the scene madison kimbrough is live near
the area where this happened and she has
more on what led up to this madison
the 8 news now i-team has learned that
the victim of this deadly stab and
happened right here on the pedestrian
bridge last night near new york new york
and the mgm grand hotel was a tourist
according to police it happened around 9
30 last night police say two men had
been involved in a verbal altercation
over an interaction with a dog the night
before then saturday night allen and the
victim got into another verbal
altercation on the bridge that's when
police say allen stabbed the victim one
time and then took off he was eventually
caught by officers authorities found
allen with a knife in his hand tourists
on the strip today say knowing this
occurred so close to them is very
concerning
yeah that's kind of scary but yeah i
could see the whole strip was closed and
we were kind of sent around the back
when we were trying to come home and uh
yeah there's a lot of homelessness
there's a lot of uh weed smoking going
on in vegas and it does feel like it's
on a downward spiral
[Music]
the victim was taken to umc where he
later died as of now we don't see any
extra security up on the foot bridge
between new york new york and the mgm
grand hotel but that may change later on
tonight reporting on the strip madison
kimbrough live local now